Si, si, si, si, si, si!
Bonjour, bonsoir et bienvenue
dans votre rendez-vous
hebdomadaire démocrate hebdo où
cette semaine nous allons
parler de la thématique santé
où nous ferons le point
ensemble sur le bilan santé de
la majorité présidentielle et
pour cela je suis en très bien
entouré ce soir en bonne
compagnie. D'abord en
distantiel Brahim Hamouche,
député de Moselle, bonsoir. et
a un petit problème technique
de son, on va essayer de régler
ça, c'est les aléas du direct
et bonsoir Cyril Zacivil,
député du Rhône. Bonsoir.
Alors, on a 30 ou 40 minutes
pour faire euh, le bilan santé,
c'est un objectif assez
ambitieux euh, je vais vous
laisser faire un petit propos
liminaire peut-être pour
présenter les enjeux finalement
de ce mandat quand vous êtes
arrivé et aujourd'hui où est-ce
qu'on en est? D'abord, merci.
Bonsoir, bonsoir à tous,
bonsoir chers amis démocrates,
maintenant citoyens. Euh, le le
donc euh on est élu maintenant
depuis plus de quatre ans euh
la problématique euh pour moi
de nos concitoyens et de notre
système de santé c'est et
j'hésiterai j'hésiterais deux
choses. Premièrement on est on
détient le record de longévité
et on le partage euh avec les
Japonais euh et les Français
par contre aussi euh un autre
record c'est de vieillir euh en
mauvaise santé. Et pour moi la
problématique elle est là, la
problématique elle est que euh
euh on a de plus en plus de
malades de de maladies
chroniques euh ce qui est
mauvais et pour l'état de santé
euh de notre population et pour
les comptes de la sécurité
sociale. Euh et c'est pour ça
que depuis quatre ans on a
essayé euh grâce à une
stratégie santé de remettre un
petit peu tout ça euh d'aplomb
euh, et et le constat qu'on
peut faire actuellement il y a
deux constats et c'est
là-dessus effectivement qu'on
pourra passer la soirée c'est
premièrement la prévention euh,
on on vit une crise de santé
publique pour moi la la
prévention c'est une santé
publique avec une approche
populationnelle euh, donc c'est
tous les enjeux de santé
publique et de prévention et
puis deuxième problématique et
je crois que tous nos
concitoyens se sentent de plus
en plus concernés c'est l'accès
aux soins, c'est pas tellement
l'accès financiers aux soins
mais c'est l'accès territorial
au soin, comment est-ce qu'on
peut accéder à un médecin, à un
professionnel de santé, euh à
un hôpital et c'est pour moi
les deux sujets qui sont
importants. En tant que
médecin, est-ce que euh vous
partagez, pardonnez-moi le jeu
de mots, ce diagnostic Euh vous
m'entendez là? Oui? Pas tout à
fait. Très très bien. Est-ce
que vous m'entendez? C'est
okay, vous pouvez y aller avec
Brahim. Oui, c'est bon.
Écoutez, oui bien évidemment
euh d'abord bonsoir à tous,
merci euh, d'organiser ce ce
débat santé qui est non
seulement un débat euh, du
quotidien mais qui sera un
enjeu euh, primordial euh, euh,
pour euh, les années à venir
car aujourd'hui nous sommes
confrontés et je partage
absolument ce que vient de dire
mon collègue Cyril sur euh, le
diagnostic territorial,
c'est-à-dire euh, euh,
aujourd'hui la difficulté euh,
à avoir accès euh, à un médecin
quelle que soit la discipline
et également euh, une
désertification qui euh, n'est
pas seulement rurale mais euh,
qui aujourd'hui se constatent
tant dans certains quartiers
euh de ville mais également
dans nos hôpitaux. Donc euh
l'enjeu majeur c'est celui de
de trouver euh de la ressource
humaine quelque soit d'ailleurs
pas au-delà de la médecine et
des médecins également dans
d'autres professionnels de
santé aujourd'hui et donc ça
nécessite euh bien évidemment
un regard euh euh budgétaire
mais également un regard
organisationnel et un regard
euh culturel. Et je crois que
ce sont les trois regards qu'il
va falloir absolument apprendre
à croire euh, pour changer les
pratiques, avoir des pratiques
avancées pour certains
professionnels, nous en
reparlerons certainement euh,
pour faire travailler la ville
et l'hôpital mais j'allais dire
c'est un vieux serpent de mer
euh, qui euh, euh, a a ses
difficultés et puis euh, pour
également euh, troisièmement
euh, euh, je dirais euh, euh,
avoir euh, anticipé et et
rendre attractif des métiers
euh, qui le sont par vocation,
qui le sont par conviction et
par formation mais qui doivent
le rester euh, tout au cours
d'une carrière et et et nos
professionnels, les
revaloriser, les considérer
euh, et les former euh, les
former parfois à d'autres
pratiques, à d'autres façons de
travailler, tout ça ce sont les
enjeux euh, qui euh, seront
peut-être abordés, mais en tous
les cas qui seront nécessaires
euh, euh, et et et de prendre à
bras le corps euh, dans dans
les les les semaines, les mois,
les années à venir. Donc,
prévention et et accès aux
soins, voilà, un échange qui
s'annonce riche, on va
peut-être commencer d'ailleurs
par la prévention, parce que ça
a été euh, peut-être la
première mesure en tout cas
santé, peut-être être même la
première action majeure du
gouvernement, ça a été une
action de prévention euh,
Brahim le on va se remettre 5
ans en arrière, 4 ans du moins
en arrière et euh, la France
est le pays qui est le plus
sceptique vis-à-vis des vaccins
et pourtant et pourtant notre
majorité fait un choix
particulièrement courageux qui
est de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire et et qui va
accentuer après cette action de
prévention durant tout le
mandat. Est-ce que vous pouvez
en faire un petit état des
lieux s'il vous plaît? Oui euh
quand nous sommes arrivés euh,
il y avait aujourd'hui des cas,
je prends un exemple de de
rougeole qui normalement est
une maladie infantile euh, qui
est bénigne et qui devrait si
nous arrivions à vacciner
l'ensemble de la population eh
bien, pourrait disparaître
comme la bariole d'ailleurs
mais on a constaté des cas de
de de rougeole euh,
réapparaître dans notre pays
euh, qui est un grand pays euh,
moderne avec une protection
sociale, une santé publique et
bien euh, cela part je dirais
en terme de vaccination euh,
des manques Donc nous avons
euh, voulu renforcer, nous
sommes passés à 11 vaccins
obligatoires, avec un certain
nombre de débats au niveau du
parlement, ça n'a pas toujours
été très simple et d'ailleurs
ce ce débat sur la vaccination
euh, a fait écho à à quelque
chose de profond dans notre
population, qui se voit
aujourd'hui un peu dans le
covid, c'est euh, parfois une
certaine réticence ou une peur
euh, sur les progrès de la
science. Et je crois que euh,
nous avons toujours euh, en
tous les cas souhaité euh,
mettre au ceuh, notre
dispositif à la fois de
prévention mais également euh,
de soins euh, les avancées que
peut apporter la science et
dans la vaccination c'est un
exemple euh, je dirais euh,
euh, quasi caricatural de de
des grandes peurs qui qui
traversent euh, nos nos nos
sociétés mais euh, que nous
avons mené jusqu'à bout et
aujourd'hui il y a 11 vaccins
obligatoires et qui permettront
à l'avenir euh, de euh, faire
disparaître un certain nombre
de maladies euh, infantiles et
c'est tant mieux les enfants
eux-mêmes et c'est tant mieux
également pour euh, euh,
l'impact que cela peut avoir au
long cours sur euh, les
conséquences que cela peut
avoir au long cours sur les
prises en charge. D'ailleurs le
d'ailleurs au-delà de la
vaccination obligatoire il y a
eu notamment aussi l'extension
par exemple du vaccin de
papioma virus pour les garçons
durant le mandat aussi qui a
été largement soutenu par le
gouvernement mais au-delà de la
vaccination la prévention ça ne
s'est pas arrêté quà cela, il
y a eu d'autres sujets qui ont
été portés par le gouvernement
n'est-ce pas Cyril? Alors, tout
à fait. J'aimerais revenir sur
sur une notion euh, qui est qui
est peu partagée euh, lorsqu'on
parle de prévention, pour moi
il y a deux types de
prévention. Il y a tout ce qui
tout tout ce qui toutes les
approches individuelles, c'est
ce qu'on peut faire
individuellement chacun pour sa
propre santé. Et il y a une
approche populationnelle.
L'approche populationnelle de
la santé, c'est ce qu'on
appelle la santé publique. La
santé publique, elle est
souvent mal définie. la santé
publique c'est une approche
populationnelle de la santé.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire? Ça
veut dire qu'on traite la pop
une population dans sa
globalité, ça peut être la
population française, pour
l'OMBS et la population
mondiale, pour un territoire
pour une région, c'est voir
effectivement quelles sont les
déterminants de santé qui est
propre à chaque région, mais
c'est d'avoir une approche
populationnelle et ça c'est
très important dans le sens où
ça fait 18 mois qu'on traverse
une crise de santé publique et
personne n'a vraiment cette
notion de santé publique et
pour moi à l'Assemblée, c'est
ce que j'ai fait, j'ai essayé
de faire depuis quatre ans,
c'est de c'est de diff cette
notion de santé publique.
Concrètement ça veut dire quoi?
Ça veut dire que lorsqu'on
parlait effectivement Brahim
parle effectivement de la
vaccination, lorsqu'on se
vaccine et c'est ce qu'on fait
actuellement c'est pas
seulement une approche
individuelle, si on se vaccine,
c'est aussi pour les autres. Si
on porte ce soir un masque,
c'est pas pour soi, c'est aussi
pour les autres. Eh ben, on
peut avoir la même approche de
prévention, donc moi je parle
moins de prévention puisque
chaque fois qu'on parle de
prévention, chacun a sa petite
idée de la prévention. Je
préfère parler de santé
publique et d'approche
populationnelle donc c'est ce
qu'on a fait par rapport aux
vaccins. Hein, on a parlé
effectivement des 11 vaccins,
du papillonatose. On peut avoir
aussi des actions assez
contraignantes sur la santé
publique, d'un point de vue
populationnelle, c'est ce qu'on
a fait sur le tabac. Une hausse
brutale du prix du paquet de
tabac, ce qui a fait
qu'effectivement que d'emblée,
on a vu effectivement diminuer
la consommation de tabac. Ça
c'est une politique par
contrainte et c'est une
politique qui touche une
population. On a pu le faire de
manière incitative. Et c'est
pour ça que c'est intéressant,
c'est qu'il y a différents
moyens de jouer sur la santé
publique. On a pu le faire de
manière incitative notamment
par exemple c'est le
Nutri-Score. Le Nutri-Score
c'est quoi? C'est qu'on a on
fait en sorte que nos
concitoyens prennent les bons
comportements en santé achètent
des produits qui soient plus
sains, ça c'est le côté citoyen
et en même temps ça force les
entreprises à produire des
produits qui soient puissants
parce qu'ils savent que grosso
modo le Nutri-Score est acheté
euh est affiché, les gens iront
plutôt vers des bons produits,
vers des mauvais donc ça aussi
incite des produits donc il y a
une il y a une méthode
coercitive, il y a des méthodes
incitatives et puis après il y
a des méthodes financières. Les
méthodes financières par
exemple on a parlé des vaccins,
rendre des vaccins obligatoires
on peut parler aussi euh, de de
entre et ça mais c'est tout on
en a pas parlé c'est la santé
sexuelle c'est de rendre
effectivement les contrats
festifs, les contraceptifs
gratuits gratuits jusqu'à l'âge
de 25 ans. On sait que ça
favorise euh, la une meilleure
santé sexuelle, que ça soit
contraceptif, que ça soit
effectivement les préservatifs,
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est une approche et pas
forcément individuelle. J'ai
aussi une petite chose, mais on
ne reviendra sans doute et pour
moi ce qui a aussi un rôle
populationnel, c'est par
exemple le 100 % santé, rendre
accessible les appareils
auditifs, ça permet de
meilleure prévention et
notamment cognitive, ça permet
effectivement on sait quà
appareiller les personnes âgées
euh, euh, s'isolent moins euh,
et gardent des des des
compétences cognitives
importantes, si aussi les
appareils dentaires hein, tout
ce qui appareil dent qui
mentionnait pas l'appareil
dentaire effectivement on se
nutritre euh, on on mange mal,
on mange moins, on mange mal et
euh, exactement comme au niveau
des des des lunettes donc euh,
c'est l'ensemble de ces mesures
hein, on on a pris depuis
depuis quatre ans on a pris
beaucoup beaucoup de mesures
moi je trouve c'est important
ce soir c'est donner une vision
de ce qu'on a fait globalement
par des mesures financières,
par des mesures coercitives,
par des mesures incitatives et
en sachant que pour le moment
on a pas encore parlé de tout
ce qui organisation euh, on a
essayé de rendre faire en sorte
que la médecine soit plus
collective et que grosso modo
que sur un bassin de vie il y a
à travers ce qu'on appelle
maintenant les CPTS, les
communautés professionnelles
territoriales de santé c'est
que il y a une approche
collective globale des des
professionnels de santé avec
des indicateurs globaux
vis-à-vis d'une population pour
faire monter cette population
en compétences en santé. Alors
peut-être avant d'arriver sur
la pluri-professionnalité, les
CPTS, qui est un vrai sujet
qu'on va aborder juste après
pour rester sur la santé
publique effectivement on est
pas resté que d'ailleurs sur la
contrainte le tabac on le
gouvernement a remboursé par
exemple les substituts
unicotiniques qui aujourd'hui
sont des médicaments comme les
autres qui peuvent être
prescrits on peut aussi voilà
effectivement citer tout ce qui
va être santé sexuelle avec
remboursement des préservatifs
ou euh, de la contraception
jusqu'à 25 ans. Vous avez
abordé le thème du cent pour
cent santé peut-être on peut le
définir Brahim qu'est-ce que le
cent pour cent santé
aujourd'hui? Qu'est-ce que ça
amène concrètement à nos
citoyens par cette action
Écoutez, 100 % santé, c'est un
reste à charge zéro,
c'est-à-dire que par exemple
pour le les appareils auditifs,
le dentaire, le visuel, ça
permet à nos concitoyens de
pouvoir euh euh se se soigner,
s'appareiller et et donc rester
en relation, la la base même de
de l'humanité, c'est-à-dire la
relation à à autrui avec son
milieu, parce que comme vient
de le rappeler euh Cyril,
quelqu'un qui entend mal va
plutôt euh s'isoler et
s'isolent ben euh chez un
personne âgée nous savons que
la des affaires intention
neurosensorielle est un facteur
de risque de déclin cognitif et
donc euh d'entrer dans une
maladie euh de la mémoire. Bon
euh ça c'est un exemple concret
que euh à partir d'un
remboursement et d'une prise en
charge euh à 100% eh bien euh
les choses ne se compliqueront
pas et nous pourrons prévenir
l'apparition euh d'une perte
d'autonomie physique ou
psychique parce que euh en
l'enjeu principal c'est euh
notamment par rapport à une
société vieillissante,
d'adapter notre société à un
vieillissement non pas
pathologique mais à un
vieillissement dit réussi,
c'est-à-dire sans perte
d'autonomie, en tout cas sans
perte d'autonomie
substantielle. Et je crois que
c'est vraiment l'enjeu, nous le
voyons bien avec une
démographie et d'ailleurs le
vieillissement est de est
devant nous, même même s'il a
bien commencé maintenant, mais
nous avons des chiffres quand
même qui annoncent une une une
un pic de âgés, eh bien euh,
l'enjeu principal à la fois
pour les acteurs de soins mais
également pour les acteurs
politiques et également pour
ceux qui vont écrire cette
feuille de route de santé
publique c'est d'avoir un
vieillissement réussi
c'est-à-dire au plus au mieux à
la maison euh, et de permettre
ce maintien à domicile dans de
très bonnes conditions et bien
évidemment de rembourser euh,
tout ce qui est appareillage
qui permette également euh,
d'avoir ce vieillissement
réussi. Voilà un exemple si
vous voulez où finalement tout
est relié, nous sommes euh, à
j'allais dire personnaliste
dans notre histoire politique
et euh ce que l'on retient à
quelque chose du personnalisme
c'est que tout est relié et là
nous avons une politique où euh
tout est relié en réalité
c'est-à-dire que à partir d'un
remboursement reste à charge
zéro nous arrivons euh à euh
prévenir euh des déclins
cognitifs, des pertes
d'autonomie et bien évidemment
un surcoût euh dans euh tout ce
qui est prise en charge. Voilà
comment à partir d'un petit euh
une petite mesure on va le dire
comme vue de l'extérieur qui en
réalité est un grand pas avec à
partir d'un petit pas nous nous
avons parfois été un peu
caricaturés pour notre
politique des petits pas mais
en réalité des petits pas qui
sont de grands pas vers quelque
chose de plus euh, je dirais
euh, autonome. Vous parlez de
politique des petits pas mais
sur la sur le maintien de
l'autonomie et le
vieillissement de la société
beaucoup de choses ont
finalement été faites même si
peut-être un regret peut-être
sur la loi grand âge et
autonomie, une grande loi n'a
pas pu voir le jour
malheureusement peut-être à
cause du covid mais en tout cas
déjà des moyens ont été mis je
crois si je ne dis pas de
bêtises. Est-ce que Brahim par
exemple vous pouvez un petit
peu détailler les les les
sommes qui ont été allouées à
l'heure actuelle, les les
financements qui ont été donnés
dans le cadre euh du
renforcement du maintien de
l'autonomie des personnes
âgées? Écoutez il y a un tarif
plancher qui a été validé au
niveau euh du gouvernement et
de notre politique qui est 22
euros. Donc c'est une vraie
revalorisation bien évidemment
nous assurerons que le le
service après-vente j'allais
dire pour que les choses se
fassent avec un juste retour
pour les acteurs euh de soins
au domicile, un tarif plancher
euh avec une concertation au
niveau des des départements
puisque c'est le chef de fila
du de de de la prise en charge
euh gérontologique on va le
dire comme ça de la personne
âgée ça reste le département et
bien évidemment euh une
dotation supplémentaire en
terme de qualité. Euh tout cela
fait aussi que nous avons euh
euh en tous les inscrit dans le
marbre la cinquième branche
dite autonomie qui a toujours
été rêvée et qui a toujours été
promise et qui n'a jamais vu le
jour nous l'avons inscrite,
l'acte de naissance est écrit
et bien euh la mandature qui
qui va venir nécessitera
également que euh cette
cinquième branche soit
maintenant euh efficiente grâce
au euh au CNSA bien évidemment
qui est euh le la partie
prenante, majeure euh dans la
mise en place de de cette
branche autonomie mais je crois
que ça c'est un événement
majeur euh au même titre la
création de la sécurité
sociale. Et je voudrais dire là
à propos de la sécurité sociale
euh, elle a prouvé notamment
avec la crise du covid qu'elle
a su tenir encore son rôle
d'amortisseur économique et
social. Euh, si nous vivons
plus longtemps, si nous nous
soignons mieux, si nous sommes
euh, au quotidien quelque soit
euh, la maladie, que ça soit
une petite maladie, un une
bobologie ou une maladie
beaucoup plus grave, voire
mortelle, nous sommes
accompagnés du premier euh, je
dirais euh, sourire au dernier
soupir à notre sécurité
sociale, qui est un bien majeur
et commun et je crois que là
encore la sécurité sociale a
montré euh qu'elle était
capable de résister aux crises
économiques sanitaires et
sociales. Donc euh je crois que
là-dessus nous avons prouvé
aussi que nous sommes très
attachés à cette protection
sociale qui euh est issue euh
des ordonnances du trois
octobre quarante-cinq et et et
cette sécurité sociale euh nous
savons aussi l'accompagner et
et ne le les dépenses de
d'assurance que nous avons voté
en termes budgétaires, montre
aussi notre particulier
attachement à cette protection
euh, sociale de chacun euh,
selon euh, cotiser selon ses
moyens et recevoir selon ses
besoins et je crois que nous
avons euh, dans l'esprit
respecté euh, fondamentalement
euh, cet esprit de de la
création de la sécurité
sociale, ça je voulais le dire
parce que c'est important on ne
peut en France en tous les cas
euh, concevoir l'amélioration
euh, de des soins et de la
santé sans sécurité sociale. Et
je crois que c'est un bien
commun et que nous avons euh,
en tous les cas dans dans la
période que nous avons euh
depuis quatre ans, montrer
notre attachement particulier
euh, à la Sécurité sociale en
lui donnant des moyens et en
euh, créant cette cinquième
branche qui permettra aussi
euh, de prévenir le
vieillissement de pathologies,
c'est-à-dire la perte
d'autonomie Une sécurité
sociale euh, du premier sourire
au dernier soupir, voilà voilà
un blows log euh, je vous
propose de revenir sur l'accès
aux soins, on a abordé de
l'accès aux soins financiers,
il y a aussi évidemment l'accès
aux soins en termes d'offres de
soins, de démographie médicale
avec évidemment un enjeu c'est
celui du médecin le
gouvernement agite sur deux
mesures majeures, d'abord
finalement supprimer le numéros
qui est peut-être d'ailleurs la
mesure la plus majeure du
projet de loi ma santé 2022
vous me direz si vous êtes
d'accord avec moi et la
deuxième mesure c'est renforcer
la plurie professionnalité et
dans cette
pluriprofessionnalité favoriser
les délégations de tâches et
cela euh, Cyril vous avez euh,
développé finalement euh, une
théorie très intéressante sur
ce sujet-là si je me trompe pas
Deux choses il faut bien que
chacun comprenne ce que c'est
que le numérous clausus. Le
micro le micro c'est bon. Le
numérus ouais ouais le numérus
clausus c'est-à-dire que
jusqu'à maintenant enfin
jusqu'à il y a trois ans
c'était le ministre qui fixait
le nombre de médecins qui
pouvaient passer en deuxième
année de médecine et donc qui
pouvait poursuivre leur
formation c'est on on vient de
fêter les 50 ans de ce numerus
clausus qui qui a fait suite
effectivement aux événements de
soixante-huit euh il faut se
rendre compte que le nombre de
médecins formés a pu baisser
jusqu'à trois-mille par an et
que depuis 30 ans, on avait une
gestion comptable de la maladie
dans l'esprit des majorités de
droite comme de gauche depuis
30 ans, depuis plus de 30 ans,
l'idée c'était de dire la santé
ça coûte cher, moins en forme
de médecin, moins on forme
d'infirmières, moins le trou où
le fameux trou de la sécu se
creusera et c'est assez bizarre
qu'il faut qu'on faut qu'on
soit que notre majorité soit
arrivée aux manettes pour que
pour supprimer une vraie
clausus et ce qui fait pour
vous donner un chiffre simple
hein donc le nombre de médecins
a pu varier depuis cinquante
ans euh, il y a euh, il y a
encore je dis trois ans on
formait euh, je dis des
chiffres grosso modo on était à
15 000 procès de santé hein,
qu'ils soient médecins euh euh,
sage-femme euh, dentiste. On
est passé de 15 000 et là de
cette année on est passé à plus
de 17 000, donc on a augmenté
d'emblée euh, le le le nombre
et et et pour moi c'est
fondamental dans le sens où on
sait très bien qu'on manque de
médecins, on manque
d'infirmières et c'est pour ça
que cette mesure est vraiment
elle est pas que symbolique,
elle est vraiment pragmatique
pour permettre, pour faire en
sorte que les que nos
concitoyens puissent avoir
accès à un médecin, une
infirmière, il manque de
médecins partout euh, que ça
soit effectivement à l'hôpital,
3000 postes vacants euh, que ça
soit en ville, que ça soit au
niveau de la médecine du
travail, que ça soit de la
médecine scolaire, il manque
des médecins partout, donc il
faut absolument former plus de
médecins. Et pour, pour moi,
c'est la première chose par
rapport à l'accès aux soins. On
sait très bien par contre que
pour former une un médecin ou
une infirmière, il faut 5, 7, 8
ans, donc euh malheureusement
on aura des de de la décision
majeure qu'on a pris seulement
dans 5, 6, 7, 8 ans. D'ici là,
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire? Je
suis persuadé que il y a il y a
un truc qui est assez
intéressant, je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez, c'est pas
vieux, il y a dix-huit mois, il
y a 18 mois, seuls les médecins
pouvaient vacciner et on
pouvait autoriser les
pharmaciens dans dans pour
certaines maladies, notamment
la grippe à vacciner. Eh ben,
cette crise a basculé tout ça.
Maintenant, tout le monde
vaccine les médecins bien
évidemment, mais effectivement
les pharmaciens les les les
pompiers, même les vétérinaires
vaccinent, donc on voit bien
que si là là-dessus voyez pour
un geste qui avant était
réservé, maintenant estimé on
se rend compte que tout le
monde peut le faire. Et donc le
le ce qu'on ce qu'on veut faire
alors moi moi effectivement
j'ai produit un rapport sur les
avec une télé qu'on appelle de
l'escalier, entre guillemets
euh, ça veut dire que chaque
professionnel peut augmenter en
compétence et peut rendre des
services plus importants au
niveau de la population. C'est
ce qu'on voit maintenant
ultimement par exemple aux
pharmaciens qui peuvent
délivrer certains médicaments.
Ça se passe au niveau des
infirmières, ce qu'on appelle
les infirmières de pratiques
avancées ou entre guillemets
maintenant une infirmière après
une formation va pouvoir entre
guillemets consulter et suivre
des patients et il faut le
faire à tous les niveaux. Euh
ça peut être effectivement tout
ce que m'appelle les manips
radios qui peuvent
effectivement commencer à faire
le diagnostic, tout ça sous un
contrôle, tout ça, tout pas un
contrôle mais une coordination
hein avec les médecins, il ne
faut pas de manière isolée mais
en collaboration, en
coordination avec le médecin,
ce qu'il faut c'est que
l'ensemble des problèmes de
santé et des des progressions
de santé, il y en a des il y en
a des dizaines euh je parle pas
effectivement des kinés, je
veux dire euh on on peut on on
a amélioré l'accès au kiné, on
a amélioré l'accès aux
orthopistes, vous savez dans de
région en France, il faut 6
mois pour voir un ophtalmo,
pour se faire prescrire des
lunettes, on a adopté euh, un
amendement euh, enfin un
article qui a permis
effectivement sous certaines
conditions parce que il faut
laisser le diagnostic au
médecin, mais sous certaines
conditions vous pourrez aller
voir votre ortoptiste pour vous
faire prescrire des lunettes et
ne pas attendre six mois. Alors
ça c'est l'accès aux soins,
après il y a un problème
d'accès territorial dans le
sens où on sait que euh il y a
les médecins étant peu
nombreux, malheureusement ils
ne ils ne s'installent pas de
manière homogène sur tout le
territoire. Et donc il y a tout
un travail et ça je pense que
nos concitoyens l'attendent, il
y a tout un travail à faire et
c'est un travail sur lequel on
on se penche euh euh un travail
programmatique pour faire des
propositions et notamment dans
le cadre de la campagne
présidentielle, pour résoudre
ce problème qui pour moi est un
problème fondamental, c'est
avoir accès au projet de santé
et avoir un égal accès aux
prochaines Antilles quel que
soit le territoire qu'on habite
on fait signe que le retour
j'aurais aimé encore aborder
quelques sujets notamment le
domaine hospitalier
malheureusement qu'on a pas eu
le temps peut-être en guise de
questions je tends une perche à
notre auditoire euh, peut-être
en guise de conclusion 5 ans de
plus qu'est-ce que vous
attendez finalement? Qu'est-ce
qui manque encore pour
améliorer notre système de
santé, Brahim Ah, écoutez ce
qui manque je crois déjà euh,
il faut le dire nous sommes
euh, nous sommes riches des
bébés des autres c'est-à-dire
que d'abord nous avons euh,
aujourd'hui euh, il faut
rattrapions ce qui n'a pas été
fait euh, depuis 20 ans, même
40 ans, si je parle de la
psychiatrie, nous pourrions
animer euh, tout un débat, mais
il y a de, voilà, de nombreuses
années que les choses auraient
dû être faites. Ce que je dis
moi souvent, c'est que euh,
chez moi en Lorraine euh, il y
a un arbre que chacun a dans
son jardin, c'est le mirabélier
et quand on le plante, il faut
euh, au moins attendre 6 à 7
ans avant qu'il puisse donner
euh, quelques fruits et puis
bien plus tard, bien de
nombreuses années plus tard et
bien il peut donner plusieurs
kilos de fruits. Donc ce que
nous ce nom aujourd'hui ce sont
bien évidemment euh ce qui
aurait dû être semé il y a de
nombreuses années euh la
suppression du numerus clausus,
les pratiques avancées ça a été
signalé Euh d'ailleurs les
pratiques avancées moi je suis
un farvent défenseur de ce que
j'ai appelé euh de la la
démédicalisation de la
médecine, c'est-à-dire que
toutes les hypertensions
artérielles ne suscitent pas
euh le cardiologue, toute euh
les euh renouvellement pour le
diabète ne n'existe pas le
diabète euh, toutes les
dépressions ne nécessitaient
pas de voir un psychiatre,
voilà. Euh, et donc il y a euh,
dans tous les champs et dans
toutes les thématiques du soin
aujourd'hui de la place pour
d'autres acteurs, d'autres
professionnels qui pourront à
la fois faire de la prévention
mais également du dépistage
euh, on l'a peut-être pas dit
mais aujourd'hui on peut euh,
faire un dépistage achivé sans
ordonnance directement euh,
dans un laboratoire euh, les
sages-femmes peuvent pratiquer
des IVG instrumentales donc il
y a quand même des domaines où
euh, il y a des compétences
artager le diabète il y a déjà
depuis très longtemps des
infirmières en éducation
thérapeutique donc tout cela je
crois que c'est la révolution
culturelle que nous devons
faire tout ne relève pas du
médecin euh même si tout
revient à la médecine mais tout
ne relève pas du médecin et je
crois que le mot important je
crois qu'il faut qu'on fasse un
véritable travail de
coordination, je crois que le
mot il est là, coordination
entre euh les euh hôpitaux,
c'est ce qu'on appelle les CHT,
coordination entre l'hôpital et
ville, avec des exercices
partagés entre la ville et
l'hôpital. Moi je ne rêvais que
d'une chose quand j'étais à
l'hôpital, c'est euh de pouvoir
euh euh faire un autre travail
que celui euh, auquel j'ai été
mobilisé, en dehors de
l'hôpital, de sortir des murs
de l'hôpital, mais mon statut
de praticien hospitalier euh
j'allais dire ne le permettait
pas euh largement. Donc là,
nous avons ouvert un certain
nombre de possibilités de
travailler et en ville et à
l'hôpital, donc je pense que
là, ça rendra bien évidemment
euh l'activité euh euh moins
administraux centrés et bien
évidemment faire venir des
professionnels euh que ce soit
les psychologues, les
sages-femmes, les kinés euh
tout tout tout ces personnels
qui peuvent aujourd'hui prendre
en charge directement euh euh
des patients avec une
coordination bien évidemment
euh dans l'ordre du médical
puisqu'on a quand même encore
un un système médico-centré
mais le médecin ne doit plus
être en première ligne
aujourd'hui, ne peut plus être
en première ligne euh, on le
voit avec les déserts médicaux
euh, la télésurveillance, la
télémédecine, le télé-soing, on
en a pas parlé mais je crois
que c'est important, maintenant
nous l'avons mis en droit en
régime de droit commun que que
ça prenne toute sa place dans
la culture et des pratiques,
donc euh, nous avons encore
euh, beaucoup de choses à faire
et cinq ans de plus euh, euh,
seront largement euh, les
bienvenus. Cyril 50 plus? Le on
a fait beaucoup mais le travail
est énorme notamment niveau de
la santé publique, de la
prévention, de l'éducation à la
santé, moi je suis persuadé
c'est que dès le projet dès le
plus jeune âge on acquiert les
bons comportements et les
mauvais comportements et ces
comportements les garde toute
sa vie. Donc au niveau de
l'éducation à la santé, au
niveau de la santé publique, au
niveau de la prévention et à
tous les âges, dès le plus
jeune âge et tout au long de sa
vie, jusqu'effectivement le
personne âgée jusqu'au dernier
soupir comme le dit Ibrahim. Ça
c'est la prévention énorme
travail à faire. C'est un
travail qui est énorme dans le
sens où on sait que le soin va
coûter de plus en plus cher, on
a des thérapies innovantes qui
sont mais qui goûte de plus en
plus cher mais entre guillemets
qui mangent un petit peu tout
le budget. Donc il faut
absolument qu'on trouve des
moyens parce que si on veut
faire une vraie politique de
santé publique de prévention il
faut absolument se donner les
moyens et c'est pas facile de
trouver les moyens vu
effectivement les les problèmes
financiers euh euh et les
problèmes du coût de la des
soins. Ça c'est la première
chose. Deuxième chose et je
regarde un petit peu ce qu'il y
a sur ce qu'a dit Ibrahim. Je
pense que le le bien évidemment
on va faire il y aura plus de
médecins, plus d'infirmières
mais la pratique de la médecine
a changé. Avant la pratique
était plutôt une pratique
solitaire isolée Euh on voit
bien que les nouveaux médecins,
les nouveaux professeurs de
santé veulent plus travailler
en groupe de manière coordonnée
et donc c'est tout tout tout le
tout l'aspect intéressant,
c'est leur donner les moyens de
travailler de manière
coordonnée. C'est vrai que le
médecin qui faisait 70 heures
par jour, ben par semaine,
c'est de plus en plus rare et
c'est normal. Et donc quelque
part ce qu'il faut c'est faire
en sorte de leur donner les
moyens de travailler de manière
de travailler en groupe. Donc
c'est les maisons de les
maisons pluridisciplinaires,
les centres de santé, les CPTS,
tout ce qui est protocole de
tout ça pour moi est essentiel
et avec des nouveaux outils qui
sont aussi assez
extraordinaires on n'en a pas
parlé mais c'est toute la
politique du numérique en santé
pour faire une bonne pour faire
pour avoir une bonne politique
de santé publique il faut avoir
des bonnes données de santé
pour que pour pour éviter tout
ce qui est gaspillage de soin
il faut faire en sorte ce qu'on
appelle le dossier médical
partagé que tout ce qui est
numérique en santé bientôt à
partir du 1er janvier vous
aurez un espace santé. Mon
espace santé où normalement il
y aura tous les documents, tout
ce qui concerne votre santé,
votre carnet de vaccination,
tout ça, tout ça est en train
de se déployer euh euh c'est
vrai que ça demande dans
certains temps pour que ça se
déploie, on on l'a voté il y a
deux, trois ans, mais donc
voilà pour moi c'est une
meilleure coordination de
l'ensemble des qui permettrait
effectivement d'avoir un
meilleur accès aux soins et
avec des outils et notamment
des outils numériques euh
notamment au niveau des données
de santé, au niveau du DM mon
espace santé, le télé civil à
la télésurveillance donc euh,
on a fait beaucoup mais il
reste encore énormément à
faire. Alors, félicitations
parce que en guise de
conclusion vous avez anticipé
beaucoup de questions notamment
sur mon espace santé où il y a
une question. Donc si par
hasard la personne qui a posé
cette question euh euh veut
plus de détails, qu'elle hésite
pas à les envoyer, je reçois
l'intégralité des questions
donc n'hésitez pas à interagir
avec euh avec nos députés. Euh
peut-être une question
effectivement, un sujet qu'on a
pas abordé et qui a été demandé
euh Sur les ruptures de
médicaments et la souveraineté
sanitaire, il semblerait que le
covid-9 a montré beaucoup de
faiblesses, qui était connu
bien antérieurement hein, en
témoigne les nombreux rapports
euh, qui avaient été publiés
avant le la crise du
coviddix-neuf. Là aussi le
gouvernement agit et agit
encore énormément finalement en
réaction à cette pandémie
mondiale. Dites-moi qui veut
prendre la parole sur sur ce
sujet-là? Peut-être Brahim?
Oui, alors sur ces questions
euh, à la fois ça fait à la
question de l'innovation
pharmacologique, la question
des stocks médicamenteux, nous
avons effectivement été
confrontés à des ruptures
notamment euh de de Curar ou
euh du mieux relaxant euh dans
nos voilà, dans nos unités euh
pendant la crise. Ce qui a
démontré effectivement notre
faiblesse en termes euh à la
fois de stock et à la fois euh
de de de d'approvisionnement.
Donc euh euh cela va faire
partie bien évidemment de la la
reconquête industrielle. Euh il
est clair euh que nous euh,
remettre de l'industrie
pharmaceutique sur notre
territoire, de refabriquer euh,
des médicaments et pas que du
Doliprane mais des médicaments
de pointe et et et là il y a
quand même euh, je dois dire 4
milliards d'euros qui sont euh,
investis dans l'innovation
pharmacologique pharmaceutique
et euh, dans les stocks nous
avons euh, mis euh, en tout cas
nous le groupe Modem euh, d'un
amendement demandant à ce qu'il
y ait pas moins de quatre mois
de stock euh, dans les
médicaments parce
qu'aujourd'hui on manque de
plus de 2400 médicaments qui ne
sont pas aujourd'hui euh, qui
sont plutôt en tension donc il
va falloir aussi que ces
médicaments en tension nous
puissions avoir euh, une
réserve suffisante. Ce qui est
le cas actuellement c'est ces
revenus j'allais dire en tout
cas les consultations qu'on
peut voir euh, au niveau des
pharmacies centrales des
hôpitaux, aujourd'hui euh,
voilà cette tension euh, a
diminué ce n'est pas celle qui
avait lors du du covid mais
nous devons euh, apprendre de
bah, du passé hein, pour que
cela ne ne se reproduise pas et
bien évidemment euh, mettre
euh, le paquet j'allais dire
sur euh, euh, les innovations
et et travailler sur ces
questions parce que nous sommes
euh, une puissance et c'est une
question de souveraineté aussi
euh, de pouvoir montrer que
nous sommes capables euh, de
produire chez nous euh, des
euh, des médicaments de pointe
et et nous en produisons euh,
notamment dans tout ce qui est
maladie euh, de type euh,
cancer et cetera mais nous
pouvons aussi produire d'autres
médicaments. Voilà, donc je
crois que c'est cela nous a
montré une faiblesse de ce
côté-là, nous la corrigeons et
nous y investissons pas moins
de 4 milliards d'euros, ce qui
n'est pas bien évidemment
négligeable et bien évidemment
euh, nous serons très vigilants
aussi sur euh, euh, bah euh, la
question euh, du prix du
médicament euh, là-dessus et
euh, du retour euh, au niveau
des grands groupes industriels
pour que euh, l'effort soit
euh, euh, partagé euh, à
hauteur de ce qu'ils peuvent
contribuer. Donc ça aussi nous
aurons une politique active,
vigilante euh là-dessus. Voilà
donc euh nous avons appris et
nous euh faisons tous les
efforts nécessaires pour que
euh corriger euh les
manquements qui a pu euh
apparaître, qui ont qui sont
apparus euh durant euh durant
la crise comique. Le fameux
Juste Prix du Médicament. Euh
est-ce que vous voulez rebondir
Cyril ou euh? Oui. Oui.
Allez-y. Pour compléter ce
qu'elle dit Brahim, la médecine
change, la pratique de la
médecine change, les
thérapeutiques évoluent. Devant
nous, on a des fabuleuses
innovations thérapeutiques.
Euh, toujours pour l'Istret,
regardez effectivement au
niveau des vaccins, au niveau
des vaccins, on a eu ces
vaccins ARN messagers qui sont
une révolution. Là on prend et
et malheureusement on s'est
rendu compte que en France on
n'a pas été bons. Alors qu'on
avait les leaders des des
vaccins. Dans toute dans toutes
les thérapeutiques, on va on va
on va on va faire des bons des
bons en avant dans les années
qui arrivent. Entre guillemets,
avant pour un autre un autre,
avant quelqu'un qui était
hypertendu, eh ben grosso modo
il allait prendre son
hypertenseur sa pilule tous les
matins pendant 30 ans. Bientôt,
effectivement, je pense qu'on a
des thérapeutiques, on prendra
un médicament une fois, deux
fois, et ça réglera le
problème. Donc euh on on le
monde du médicament va être
bouleversé. Là-dessus, le
Président de la République a
vraiment un portage politique
fort pour dire que grosso modo,
la France doit se resituer au
niveau des innovations. En
France, on est on est plus on
est très bon dans l'innovation,
on a quà avoir un exemple hein
le l'ARN Messager quelque part
c'est un Français. Le problème
c'est qu'en France on a les
bonnes idées, on a une
recherche fondamentale qui est
bonne, par contre après
qu'est-ce qu'on a pas? On a pas
les les les moyens
d'investissement pour
développer effectivement une
une production et c'est ça pour
moi qui est très important
c'est qu'on se redonne les
moyens qu'on qu'on favorise les
thérapeutiques innovantes,
qu'on favorise les laboratoires
qui investissent sur ces et et
les aider pour investir sur ces
nouveaux médicaments et je
pense que là-dessus la France
est très bien placée parce que
en recherche fondamentale on
est très bon par contre
effectivement c'est le le le
reste qui va qui qui va moins
bien après pour ce qui est de
la production moi je suis plus
dubitatif hein la le le le pour
reprendre effectivement le
paracétamol, le paracétamol
était produit effectivement
dans dans ma région euh euh
l'arrêt de la production on
s'est arrêté il y a il y a un
peu moins de 20 ans pourquoi?
Parce qu'en même temps pour du
paracétamol, il faut servir de
bain zen. et bain zen c'est
quoi? C'est la filière qui est
la plus polluante. Est-ce que
nos concitoyens sont prêts à
avoir une usine qui produit du
blasen, du du chlorobin zen à
côté de chez eux, j'en suis pas
sûr et c'est pour ça que
malheureusement ces produits on
les laisse plutôt faire. Euh
euh en Inde ou en Chine euh
après il y a un problème de de
de d'industrie, de chimie
lourde et de chimie lourde qui
doit être de plus en plus
propre et acceptée par tous.
j'ai j'ai encore deux questions
pour moi qui qui effectivement
on n'a pas du tout abordé ces
sujets-là et donc qui se serait
intéressant. J'ai une question.
Je crois que la personne a
voulu parler de de la loi Grand
Age Automime et d'un point de
vue sociétal où euh où il
m'écrit, qu'en pensez-vous
qu'elle va être mise en place
et quels seront les sujets
abordés? Parce qu'effectivement
on a été comme je disais le
mandat actuel, la majorité
présidentielle a mis des
financements aujourd'hui pour
valoriser notamment les
carrières liées au grand âge et
à l'autonomie. Mais finalement,
comme vous le disiez Ibrahim,
c'est une c'est un système tout
en qu'il va falloir adapter
pour la transition
démographique. Alors qu'est-ce
qu'on ne peut attendre
finalement sur cette future
grande loi du grand âge et de
l'autonomie qui devrait arriver
sûrement au prochain mandat et
sûrement assez rapidement?
Peut-être Cyril peut regarder
le premier? Je te sens. D'abord
une petite chose. Il faut que
vous soyez tous conscients que
le premier député qui a posé le
premier amendement pour créer
la cinquième branche est un
député modem. Après on a été
suivi et quelque part est fier
que ça soit effectivement
quelque chose qui qui qui soit
venu du Modem. au départ
personne m'a cru et puis
finalement euh, on a on on on a
embarqué tout le monde, ça
c'est la première chose. Au
niveau du grand âge autonomie
plusieurs choses. Premièrement,
il y a bien évidemment le
problème des métiers, les
métiers du grand âge sont peu
attractifs et c'est ce qu'on a
essayé de faire, c'est les
revaloriser. Est-ce que vous
savez un petit peu combien de
personnes c'est un chiffre qui
est toujours intéressant?
Combien de de de personnes
s'occupent des gens du grand
âge? il y en a neuf-cent-mille,
900 000 personnes s'occupent
effectivement des personnes
âgées et entre guillemets on
sait, comme l'a présidé Ibrahim
avec le vieillissement, il va
falloir trouver dans les années
qui arrivent hein, deux00,
trois00 000 personnes en plus
euh, et et et il faut rendre
ces métiers attractifs donc le
le euh, et en sachant que
l'état de convention collective
donc tout ça est compliqué mais
sur le grand âge au niveau du
métier on a on a progressé on a
mis les moyens on a mis
deux-cents plus cinq-cents
millions donc on a mis les
moyens pour invarier. Après il
y a il y a il y a un autre
problème c'est le problème de
la gouvernance les arbitrages
par rapport à ça sont pas
faits. Si vous connaissez le
dossier ça ça relève et des
départements et des ARS en
sachant que certains s'occupent
plus des EHPAD, d'autres plus
du domicile et quelque part il
faut trouver un arbitrage entre
les deux, la CNSA, la Caisse
Nationale, Solidarité pour
l'autonomie peut être peut être
cet élément. En tout cas c'est
comme ça qu'on l'a vu dans le
texte de la cinquième de la
cinquième branche, c'est la
CNSA qui portera qui sera
l'effecteur et qui peut être
les tampons entre le le les
départements et et les ARS. Euh
après il y a le sujet de la
prévention, on revient toujours
à la prévention, on sait
comment vieillir en bonne
santé. Euh et puis après il y a
le problème de l'argent, il y a
eu beaucoup de rapports qui ont
été faits sur euh ça encroule à
Ibrahim, on croule sous les
rapports depuis quatre ans
concernant le concernant
l'autonomie, on sait que euh et
en tout cas si Libo, c'est le
rapport Libo qu'il avait
chiffré, il faut 10 milliards
hein pour le moment on a
apporté euh, grosso modo un
milliard, on sait qu'il faudra
encore plus d'argent, après
c'est comment le trouver, tout
le monde est d'accord, pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a fait une
cinquième branche? C'est qu'on
est tous persuadés que ça doit
relever en grande partie de la
solidarité nationale et ça l'en
revient effectivement à
l'importance de la sécurité
sociale et de maintenant de ces
quatre branches et de
maintenant de sa cinquième
branche. Brahim peut-être
quelque chose à ajouter? Oui
sur la personne âgée, je crois
qu'il y a un mode un maître mot
ou un mot c'est la classe,
c'est la question de la place.
Place de la personne âgée dans
notre société, la place au
domicile, la place en EHPAD, la
place temporaire en EHPAD, la
place temporaire dans des
unités euh, d'hébergement,
d'accueil de jour, d'accueil
temporaire, euh, de mon
expérience, mais pas politique,
celle-là, de mon expérience
professionnelle. Je sais
combien des familles sont
confrontées euh, souvent euh,
au placement euh, d'un papa,
d'une maman et puis d'une autre
maman et du conjoint, en tout
cas, de, quand le papa est
classé, la maman, ben, c'est
compliqué. Donc, il y a Whisky,
l'accessibilité financière, à
ces placements qui sont, qui
sont vraiment douloureux une
vraie souffrance au sein des
familles. Euh donc euh là c'est
vraiment euh c'est une question
euh politique, sociétale mais
également euh humaine et
philosophique existentielle de
de savoir quelle est la place
de la personne âgée. Euh moi à
titre personnel bien
évidemment, je suis pour un
maintien à domicile, aussi
longtemps que cela puisse être
nécessaire et possible. Donc
nous avons parlé tout à l'heure
du virage numérique mais euh je
crois qu'il y a aussi tous des
questions de domotique qui
permettront aussi de régler des
questions notamment de la
chute, des incontinences, tous
les facteurs qui entraînent
souvent des des placements et
voir des placements définitifs,
parce que faut savoir que dans
la psychologie d'une personne
âgée, tout changement de repère
habituel est un véritable
traumatisme en terme de faculté
d'adaptation. Et donc euh avec
une désadaptation. Qui risque
d'être maintenu euh et donc euh
finalement une perte
d'autonomie. Ceux euh que l'on
sur lequel nous voulons
absolument lutter. nous on veut
promouvoir l'autonomie et et
voilà donc euh moi je pense
qu'un des mots clés dans une
grande politique d'une grande
loi âge et dépendance, c'est le
mot place. Place déclinée en
placement, emplacée, en voilà.
Quelle est la place de la
personne âgée? Et pardon Le
voilà et à partir de ce terme
de place, je crois qu'on peut
décliner de vraies politiques
de santé publique et puis il y
a les Ehpad dit hors les murs,
les euh personnellement moi je
ne plaide pas pour continue à
construire des Ehpad comme on
en a construit et euh chaque
commune veut son EHPAD et puis
on en construit une deuxième,
une troisième alors qu'on voit
bien que les ressources
humaines ne sont pas là, que
euh les difficultés euh ne vont
que euh en augmentant, il faut
pouvoir déplacer les EHPAD à la
maison, pouvoir euh accueillir
transitoirement,
provisoirement, temporairement
des personnes âgées dans des
allers-retours. Le aller-vert
pour moi signifie faire des la
grande politique de santé
publique, je crois que c'est
au-delà de aller vers, c'est
aller-retour, c'est-à-dire quà
un moment donné, on a besoin
d'être hébergés dans des murs.
À un moment donné, on a besoin
que ce soit les professionnels
qui viennent à la maison. Et
tout ça, nous avons encore un
système cloisonné. Un système
en si haut, un système qui
parfois ne fonctionne pas euh
dans l'intérêt, je vais le
dire, même si c'est pas
politiquement correct, dans
l'intérêt euh du de du terme un
peu barbare des usagers, en
tous les cas des personnes mais
plutôt dans des logiques
institutionnelles. Et ça je
pense que la force du politique
c'est de dire que les
institutions doivent dorénavant
euh s'entrechevaient et
travailler euh non pas
seulement ensemble mais
également dans euh un sens
autour et pour euh le patient
en tout cas dans sa volonté.
Euh dans son euh consentement
pour utiliser un autre terme
plus euh euh plus juridique
mais également euh plus
éthique. C'est que l'on accepte
aussi qu'une personne âgée
puisse finir et déterminer sa
vie à domicile et et ne pas le
placer parce que ben il y a des
difficultés derrière mais faire
venir les professionnels pour
euh faire une expertise du lieu
de vie euh voir avec tous les
partenaires euh faire le soin à
domicile, se donner les moyens
de travailler en réseau et puis
bien évidemment fournir euh
derrière euh tous les
dispositifs porteurs et je
crois que le mot encore fois
place est un mot essentiel dans
une politique du grand âge. Et
je ne désespère pas que cette
politique du grand âge verra le
jour dans un dans le parce que
nous avons fait passer beaucoup
de choses dans des amendements
et dans le projet de loi de
finances sécurité sociale
2022, mais bien évidemment euh,
cela ne peut pas remplacer ne
serait-ce qu'au point de vue
symbolique euh, une grande loi
qui signifierait que oui nous
avons conscience des
difficultés, oui nous avons une
considération les souffrances
du quotidien et oui nous y
répondons par la force de la
politique qui est là aussi pour
répondre aux grands enjeux, les
grands défis et celui-ci, celui
du vieillissement euh, il est
euh, il est plus qu'urgent
Alors, malheureusement j'avais
encore de nombreuses questions
que j'ai reçues mais on me fait
signe qu'il est temps de
conclure. Alors, une petite
seconde. Allez-y. Si je peux
conclure deux secondes vous
avez sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale, vous avez nos
adresse mail que ce soit Brahim
et moi, si vous avez des
questions, n'hésitez pas hein,
alors soit via le le siège,
soit via nos boîtes, nos nos
boites mails. Envoyez-nous vos
questions, on essayera d'y
répondre, non seulement les
questions, puis en même temps
c'est vrai qu'on rentre dans
une période qui est
intéressante, qui est une une
période d'élection où on
réfléchit effectivement sur le
programme, nous effectivement
on travaille depuis 4 ans, mais
je pense que la force de notre
mouvement c'est que vous-même
je suis sûr que vous avez des
idées, des propositions, pareil
n'hésitez pas à nous faire
remonter euh des propositions
pour améliorer système de santé
et d'autonomie, il en a bien
besoin. Merci. Voilà, le
rendez-vous démocrate hebdo
s'achève. Euh, petit point
d'information tout de même, la
trêve des confiseurs arrive,
donc le démocrate hebdo ne sera
pas n'aura pas lieu la semaine
prochaine. Il aura lieu le 5
janvier sur la thématique de
notre défense. Euh, quant à
moi, je vous remercie de nous
avoir écouté, j'ai été ravi
d'échanger avec vous, avec
Cyril, avec Brahim, c'était
passionnant et euh, j'espère
qu'on aura d'autres occasions
pour en parler car beaucoup de
pro encore euh, vont être créés
dans le cadre des élections qui
arrivent. Merci à tous. Merci à
vous.